رجب طيب اردووان نهايه السبعينات انضم الى
حزب الخلاص الوطني بقياده نجم الدين
اربكان
عام
1983 عاد للساحه السياسيه كقيادي في حزب
الرفع
عام
1994 انتخب رئيسا لبلديه اسطنبول
1997 اضطر الى الاستقاله
عام
1998 ودين بتهمه التحريض على الكراهيه
الدينيه اقصي عن الحياه السياسيه
يوليو 2001 انجازت له المحكمه الدستوريه
العوده للسياسه
اغسطس 2001 اسس حزب العداله والتنميه الذي
يتراسها
عام 2002 فاز حزبه بالانتخابات التشريعيه
[موسيقى]
2014 فاز بانتخابات الرئاسه كاول رئيس
منتخب مباشره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات